Let's talk a little bit about the Matt Gates
scandal. The Matt Gates scandal broke while
we were on vacation last week. Republican
Congressman Matt Gates is under investigation
for a whole bunch of things, including possible
child sex trafficking. Matt Gates, after word
of this investigation came out, appeared
on Fox News with Tucker Carlson last week,
I guess, to plead his innocence. But he ended up
actually sort of further incriminating himself,
even at one point saying to Tucker, Tucker,
don't you remember? You went to dinner with
me and a girl I was with. And Tucker claimed,
I don't know what you're talking about. I mean,
you couldn't script a more bizarre story. And
now we are starting to get into the phase of
how serious could the crimes Matt Gates may be
accused of be when it comes to consequences? Well,
Dave Aronberg, who's a state attorney for Palm
Beach County, Florida, was on MSNBC yesterday
explaining that child sex trafficking,
one of the possible crimes Gates could
be charged with. It can come with a penalty
of life in prison. Take a look at this video.
Legal liability that Gates is facing here. We
just ran through quite a few very distasteful
things. Which of them may end up being
crimes that Matt Gates could be charged with?
Well, good morning, Casey. The most
serious crime is child sex trafficking,
which is punishable by up to life in prison. And
there is a 10 year mandatory minimum. And the more
information that comes out, the fewer defenses
Matt seems to have left, because Joel Greenberg,
the former tax collector of Seminole County,
is being charged with child sex trafficking
over the same 17 year old girl at issue.
So the point here is not for me to tell you
Matt Gates might end up in prison for life. I'm
not telling you. I believe Matt Gates is going to
end up with life in prison. The point here is that
what Matt Gates is wrapped up in could come with
a sentence of life in prison. Now, Matt Gates is a
privileged member of Congress, one of four hundred
and thirty five. He will get top notch defense
attorneys. There's no way in hell that Matt Gates
at the tail end of this ends up with life in
prison. But the point is, a normal person might
be at risk of life in prison based on what Matt
Gates is being investigated for doing. Meanwhile,
every time Matt Gates tries to explain why he's
not guilty of anything, he seems to raise more
questions and further incriminate himself. In the
Tucker Carlson interview last week, Gates said,
I've never paid anyone for sex. And at
that time, that wasn't even part of the
known investigation right at the gates, bringing
new elements into presenting derogatory evidence
about himself during interviews. Further, Matt
Gates said, Just look at my congressional travel
records. They're going to exonerate me. Now, when
that Gates refers to his congressional travel
records, by definition, his congressional travel
records would only refer to his official travel.
The disclosures that Gates filed with the
House Ethics Committee and the Federal Election
Commission regarding his official trips don't
include the stuff that he was talking about on
Fox News, on Fox News, he said check the records
were going to provide them. They provided them,
but it's only his official travel. The documents
that Gates put out don't include who traveled with
Gates on a personal basis on the trips. They don't
include what payments did Gates make for other
people to travel with him personally, not as part
of his official congressional travel reservations.
And there's all sorts of trips that he made
to Las Vegas, to Yale University University,
where anybody could have gone with him. And he.
You might have paid for it personally, it wouldn't
show up in congressional travel records,
we would have no idea about it. So, again,
by raising the issue of travel records, he raises
more questions about his personal travel spending,
who he paid for trips for. Did they cross
state lines, how old were they, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera. Then Gates claims he's
being extorted over supposedly bogus fraudulent
investigations by the FBI. That was his claim. His
dad is being extorted. He's being extorted. OK,
that puts the spotlight on the investigations.
And we realize, hold on a second,
these investigations are more serious and far
more broad ranging than we initially thought
that Gates might have done even more bad
stuff than what we initially believed.
So the more we learn, every time Gates tries
to assert his innocence, the worse it gets and
the worse we suspect his actions of actually
being. Now, of course, he's innocent until
proven guilty. There's no question about that. You
know, every time we talk about stories like this,
I'll get emails from right wingers saying, do you
not believe in innocent until proven guilty? Yeah,
we do. We're reporting on allegations. We
report on allegations when they're against
Democrats and people on the left. We're talking
about what the investigation is looking at.
We're talking about how every time he
opens his mouth, he seems more guilty.
Of course, you are innocent and strictly
speaking, you're innocent until proven
guilty. There's no no doubt. And he deserves a
lawyer and a defense and all of that stuff. Then
you add to this that Gates was the only vote in
the House of Representatives against an anti human
trafficking bill in twenty seventeen. That takes
on a whole new meaning and dimension based on
what he's now accused of. We've now learned that
when Matt Gates was in the Florida legislature
before he was in the US House of Representative
Gates opposed a bill meant to stop people from
sharing what we call revenge porn, which is
sexually explicit images of ex relationships.
Because Gates believed if you have those images
from when you were in the relationship, those
are yours to share. That takes on a whole new
meaning. In light of the allegations about Gates
sharing pictures with other members of the
House of Representatives on the House floor,
this is the guy that wears his membership in the
supposed party of family values on his sleeve.
And this is the reality that he's actually living.
I would love to see all of this come crashing
down. We have a poll that you can vote in asking,
what do you think will be the eventual outcome
of the Matt Gates scandal? It's on our YouTube
community tab. Go to YouTube, dotcom slash The
David Pakman Show. Click on Community. You can
vote in the poll. We'll have results later this
week. And of course, we will publish those
results to our Instagram, which you can find
at David Pakman show. And if you want to see
the vacation picture I posted that cost me
one hundred followers, which isn't that much,
actually. But OK, I'm trying to be hyperbolic
here. The picture that cost me one hundred
followers follow me on Instagram at David Pakman